What is the
Europe plans to do for young people
in these elections?
Not bad,
That's the question.
Yes,
it's from you,
it's yes,
I don't have a
Bravo,
but this is a very important question.
But of course,
you are right to talk about young people,
because today, me,
what marks me,
is that it is those who are
today the least
the least concerned by this election,
who feel the least concerned.
And that's a huge problem because it's,
I say it again, it is,
it is our future that is decided.
You know, young people
today,
they are concerned about the future
because they have the impression that,
they a world
which is going through crises.
Everywhere,
wherever we project ourselves,
we have the impression that
we will live less well than our parents,
worse than our.
And that,
deep down,
I would like to say to
to all the young people,
since you ask me the question,
there are 2 ways to negotiate,
or
we are in the gallery,
we watch the game that takes place on the field
and we are sorry
because it feels like
that nothing is going in the right direction,
or we go down to the field
and we commit and act.
And whatever your beliefs,
whatever your ideas,
you can take action.
We are lucky to live in a democracy,
It means that our future is in our hands.
Democracy is not,
it is not won Of course,
eh,
the fact that we are free.
And you know that freedom today,
it is attacked from everywhere
by the fact that we have the
opportunity to say our opinion,
to share our ideas
and above all to act to ensure that
things are moving in the right direction.
Thank you. It's a little,
it's 1 it's 1 little vague as an answer anyway.
Thank you.
So that's it.
That's the political specialty.
1 specific question at the time,
because young people,
they are interested in many topics,
do we have to go? Do we?
So, uh.
You're going to call it on 1 specific topic.
Here, will you call after?